they've trekked hundreds of kilometers
trampling crops and damaging buildings
along the way
their journey has captured the
imagination of millions of people
following online
but it's less entertaining for those in
their path
i was scared we came out and saw an
elephant that was about three meters
tall
it really scared us a baby elephant even
ran into our wall before running away
the herd was wandering into the village
all day long
the herd of 15 wild elephants is from a
nature reserve on china's southwestern
border with laos
since setting out in spring last year
they've walked nearly 500 kilometers
north
and are now near the city of kunming the
provincial capital of yunnan state
it's home to around 8.5 million people
the authorities are trying to keep the
elephants out by forming a barricade
with heavy trucks
we are here to block the elephants
traffic police will tell us what to do
in details
we received a notice at noon we are a
truck team
and traffic police officers said they
need some trucks as long as i'm needed i
will stay here
animal scientists say they don't know
why the elephants left their home
china's elephant population has grown in
recent years as a result of conservation
efforts
but at the same time deforestation has
reduced their habitat
so far the herd has caused more than one
million dollars worth of crop damage
but no one's been injured officials are
tracking the elephants movements by
drone
where they'll go next nobody knows when
they'll stop
is also unclear victoria gatenbee
al jazeera